and if you listen to Susan and Francis,
you get to this point where you say,
"These guys have this extraordinary sense of dignity
about the way they're achieving their power,
the sense of ownership and the sense of pride,
and I'm going to flip into a little tiny video clip,
which is from a distributor of one of these companies that I'm talking about.
And he puts it better than anyone I've ever heard it.
So just listen to this.
Martin: So if it does happen that we get to a point
where every home has their own independent supply of energy,
that will give us the democracy of energy.
That's it.
And everybody has that choice,
and everybody knows when they want to switch it on or off,
whether they want to sell access or whether they want to store it.
That freedom getting back into the hands of the consumer,
that would be the most exciting thing.
Amar Inamdar: Brilliant, right? That was Martin,
and he has a really wonderful turn of phrase,
and what a sense of vision that he captures.
So picture that for a moment:
every household a proud producer as well as consumer of energy ...
the ability to generate power, to share power, to sell power,
all coming from your own generating asset sitting on your own property.
Maybe even think about crowdsourcing with your neighbors
the grid from the ground up,
rather than waiting for the government to bring it from the top down.
So in Africa, we have this extraordinary opportunity right now,
an extraordinary opportunity,
to change the world and create an energy system
that everybody will be jealous of,
and everybody will look to us as the innovators of.
And that's the democracy of energy.
Thank you very much.
(Applause)
Chris Anderson: Quick question.
So it's a really exciting vision.
Help us understand, what are the key roadblocks right now?
Like, what could make this go faster?
AI: So the first one, I think, is really the intermittency of solar power.
So the problem is that the sun only shines for 12 hours a day,
so you've got darkness for 12 hours a day,
and we need to have storage solutions
that are better to help us take us down that path.
So storage is really one.
CA: And those prices are coming down.
AI: And those prices are coming down very quickly.
Second, the appliance set.
So it needs to get more efficient,
and it needs to get more diverse.
We need to do more of the things
we in Africa want to do with the appliance set.
CA: DC appliances.
AI: DC appliances,
and I think there's a real opportunity there, Chris.
I think the opportunity
is that we could shift some of these 21 billion dollars of subsidies
that governments are spending on the current electricity system
and we could promote R&D here in Africa
to create some of these products,
to be some of these entrepreneurs, and make this happen.
So create this new system here.
CA: And some of the companies themselves,
I mean, there's plenty of demand there.
What's holding them back from supplying that demand?
I mean, some of them talk about,
they would like to sell 10x what they can currently sell.
AI: Exactly. So for many of these capitals,
it's that markets don't price consumer risk very well,
and particularly in markets like ours,
in emerging markets and here in Africa.
So there's not enough working capital coming into this space
because the big financiers look at this space and say,
"I don't know how to price that risk, so I'm going to stay away from it."
And that's holding a lot of these companies back.
CA: Well, it's incredibly exciting to picture what could happen here.
In my mind, this might be the biggest leapfrog of them all.
And thank you for all you're doing and for sharing that vision
so powerfully.